the NAACP starting a huge battle with
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis America's
most prominent civil rights organization
issuing a travel advisory and warning
black Americans not to even go to the
Sunshine State it's over what they claim
is an openly hostile environment for
black and lgbtq Americans and that
DeSantis is making quote aggressive
attempts to erase black history into
restrict diversity equity and inclusion
programs in Florida schools the group's
leader was doubling down on all of this
earlier
the governor has perfected the art of
doing stunts to gain campaign
contributions unfortunately this will
impact people's lives we should not use
race or othering as a tool to weaponize
against people and it unfortunately for
a large percentage of the Floridians
that's what he has done therefore we are
advising African-Americans and others
that if you travel to Florida beware
that your life is not valued that we
have a political landscape that could
cause harm
team DeSantis responding to the travel
advisory calling the whole thing a stunt
and Florida's Republican Congressman
Byron Donald is slamming the move
entirely
this is silly and it's dumb it's
political it makes no sense we should be
focused on making sure people actually
have the opportunity to achieve which
Florida is actually doing and thriving
in way better than other states let's
say New York or California or Washington
State we're doing a significantly better
job helping black Americans succeed and
it's not just about me it's about all
the millions of black people that live
in our state
Jesse how much do you think the NAACP
believes it's hurting DeSantis versus
how much this could actually help him
well it's a clever strategy they worked
it out with the media they know that
DeSantis is announcing the governor he's
going to be president or he's running so
they know this week is where it's going
to happen so when you announce this
boycott you're basically telegraphing to
the media whenever you mention Ron
desantis's name is running
48 hours ago the NAACP announced a
boycott so that's basically a subliminal
message to Black Americans don't travel
don't go there Ron DeSantis is going to
harm you so that's tricky what they did
there AOC was just in Miami partying you
know it's not like the Florida Gators
freshman recruiting class is going to
decommit and go to Clemson everyone is
moving to Florida black population in
Florida is exploding for good reason
it's not just the weather they have like
the low taxes low business taxes you can
get concealed carry there I don't think
a lot of black parents want trans
education for six-year-olds either and
who does the NAACP want to be Governor
Gillum a guy who was a meth addict who
had a secret sex life come on everybody
knows that no one listens to these
travel advisories anyway I told
everybody not to go to Mexico my own
producer went to Cancun so no one
listens to this
that and that hurt
but the whole thing's based on a smear
this AP African-American history thing
they teach the Civil War they teach
reconstruction they teach the Civil
Rights Movement they just didn't want to
teach queer Theory so this is the NAACP
trying to stay relevant trying to get in
the news and try to raise money turns
out the chair of the NAACP actually
lives in Tampa yeah yeah yeah I don't
think he's probably going to move Greg
the other thing is that they have more
black owned businesses in Florida than
California on the uh what do you call
that when you do the math when you dog
paddle what are you talking about like
for pot for their population oh okay
yeah I get a percentage of population
there you go you know this funny but it
is weird NAACP doing a travel warning
are we going to get like is the Triple A
going to have a policy on reparations
the FAA can give us their thoughts on no
cash bail but they're right you have to
understand they're writing a whole state
off I mean it is kind of I mean it's
kind of bizarre and you get the sense
that it's not about white people I mean
it's not about black people it's about
white people so it's not racist but it
is kind of racist they're saying don't
go there because you don't want to be
around these white people I think what
happened was the NAACP I hate to use the
phrase Jumping the Shark but it truly is
a stunt that you do when you become you
are no longer relevant it was from Happy
Days this is truly what you do when you
realize you can't catch up anymore the
woke have out woke you you're like
trying anything they realize Florida is
attracting so many people and this red
State just keeps getting bigger and
bigger so they created a dimorphous
vague threat like lack of inclusion in
schools I mean it's so V it's so
ridiculous that's not a danger to you
physically but what if more blacks keep
leaving and from the leaving terribly
run cities and going to Florida what
happened since then they have to stop
that this is not just this is not just
about DeSantis it's about keeping uh
keeping Florida from turning super red
and losing all of these people from
other states
and it was an interesting judge last
night I watched local news here in New
York and for the first eight minutes the
stories were about crime all across the
city Rand and I told Peter I'm like and
those are just the ones they were able
to report on right here man I remember
random and then the ninth minute the
story was about don't go to Florida yeah
you know you would think that if the
NAACP wanted to issue a travel advisory
to African-Americans to Black Americans
they would say you know what don't go to
Chicago don't go to Baltimore don't go
to cities where gangs are more likely to
kill you if you're black but the truth
is that the naact isn't concerned about
blacks they're only concerned about a
political narrative political ideology
and that ideology is Rhonda santis is a
bad man and I think Al Sharpton said he
was a racing African-American history
you know
um which is kind of Rich coming from the
group that has been tearing down our
statues and and and basically taking the
names of presidents off of schools in
high schools but but their their agenda
is not about being concerned for African
Americans it's just political and I
think that in recent years so much has
come out that I don't know if everyone
else feels this way but I really feel
like everyone like gets it now the
hypocrisy is so great it's so in your
face the veil has been pulled back
everybody knows that when people are in
politics and or or a part of something
that doesn't make sense you know it's
because they've got a political payback
coming for them it's just different now
it's interesting we're waiting for a
call for I think they're going to add
here let's do this now and then we'll
get to Tulsi a guest on MSNBC is now
calling Florida a terrorist State can
you play that
I just took my family to spring break in
Florida recently and I think about all
of the folks who traveled there for Sun
and joy and peace and restoration and to
be reminded that actually this is
getting to the point where Florida is
about to be a terrorist state to many of
us here in America certainly as a
lesbian as a black woman I don't want to
have anything to do with the place
um and I think about all the other
people who don't want to travel there
either and so I think it was very clever
on behalf of the NAACP I thank them for
issuing this broad guidance
as Jesse said clever or sneaky I talked
to Lawrence Jones earlier today and said
what do you think he said well so now
black kids don't get to go to Disney
either this does not seem fair
the question for I think but she's a
democratic strategist so what is the
strategy because Ron DeSantis actually
increased vote totals with Hispanics and
blacks in this last election when he won
over by 19 points so I don't understand
what the strategy is yeah it is it is it
is an attack against Ron DeSantis on the
week that he's going to announce but I
think to your point Greg about relevancy
if you look at where Florida is now
versus where Florida used to be my
grandfather served in the Air Force he
was stationed at uh Eglin Air Force Base
so my dad went you know he grew up there
in the panhandle of Florida and you know
he was the only person of color in his
class as a third grader and here I've
he's told this story he remembers it
vividly where he's sitting in the
classroom the teacher's going around and
asking all the kids okay tell me your
name and where you're from so my dad
says hi my name is Mike and I'm from
Samoa and the teacher says uh Mike is
that country in Africa all the kids
started laughing and from that point on
he was called the n-word none of the
kids would play with him he was chased
out of uh you know white bathrooms and
away from a water white white labeled
water fountains and so he directly
experienced what how things used to be
so frankly there's a there's a positive
and negative to the story the negative
of course is the NAACP is racializing
and weaponizing racism for political
benefit the positive is it's a testament
there to their success in the Civil
Rights era that they have done so much
good that that the Florida my dad grew
up in is not the Florida that kids are
growing up in today you're not seeing
that kind of racism discrimination uh
and frankly the hatred and so many
others went through it's a kind of rent
seeking where they need they have to
create something they have to create
something or they're out of a job yeah
or like why don't you try to compete on
the issues yeah
labeling him uh racist and saying don't
go to Florida doesn't mean you're going
to end up winning Florida that means
basically you're throwing in the towel
you're not even going to compete in
Florida as the Democratic strategist
just explained all right everyone I'm
Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now